so let's get the inside story on the
memo from the man in charge
Devin Nunez is the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee that released
this document mr. chairman thanks for
joining us great to be with you brother
what do you think the biggest takeaway
from this memo is in your eyes well I'm
sad that we had to get to this point we
should have never never been here it's
unfortunate I didn't want to have to do
this but the sad part is is that I have
an obligation to the American people
when we see FISA abuse so these are
secret courts that exist to target for
foreigners for catching terrorists or
catching people who might be bad actors
and the American citizens that are
represented before this court have to be
protected and the only place that can
protect them is the US Congress when
abuses do occur did you rise well it's
not a place we wanted to go it's not a
place we wanted to go but it's where we
had to go did you write it myself trey
gowdy
are two investigators and then obviously
checked by the lawyers and the rest of
our committee members did you read the
actual Phi sub applications
no I didn't the and this has been one of
these bogus news stories that have been
put out so the agreement we made with
the Department of Justice was to create
a reading room and allow one member and
two investigators to go over and review
the documents I thought the best person
on our committee would be the chairman
of the Oversight Committee trey Gowdy
who has a long career as a federal
prosecutor to go and do this and then
they over a series of meetings would
come back with their notes and brief the
rest of the committee members did you or
anyone on your committee coordinate in
any way with President Trump were the
administration on the release of this
memo no in fact that's no we in fact we
opened up an investigation into DOJ and
FBI for FISA abuse and other matters
last summer in the summer of 17 with
president Trump's lawyers in any way
no outside conservative groups just one
today put out an ad that's targeting rod
Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney General
saying that he needs to do his job or
quit
and he it seems like it was timed out
but did you work with any outside groups
in the formulation in this memo no no I
didn't in fact I personally like rod
Rosenstein but look the bottom line here
is is both most Minister Rosenstein mr.
sessions attorney General Sessions and
director Ray have work to do and they
can't start doing their work to root out
the problems if you don't admit first
that you have a problem and they've been
unwilling to do that
but but no I don't work with outside
groups on this the FBI DOJ other Intel
agencies all say there are material
omissions in this memo what it what did
you leave out is there is there
justification for the FBI behavior
detail in this memo that that we have
yet to learn yeah so so we look
specifically at just FISA abuse we
wanted to keep sources and methods out
if you remember 10 days ago we were
accused of a lot of things especially
that we were going to disclose our
nation's top secrets I think everybody's
learned that was a total fallacy that
was put out by the left and the
mainstream media we didn't disclose any
secrets part of that is we had to take
all of this information and reduce it
down into into a summary with just the
pertinent facts about the FISA abuse the
only area that I am familiar with that
we we left out would be the the history
of Carter page I explained why we left
this out to the director of the FBI the
director FBI is well aware of my
concerns about mr. page and I don't
believe that somebody like mr. page
should be a target of the FBI especially
using salacious information paid for by
a political campaign like this dossier
was about mr. page and then supplemented
by a news story that was that was / that
was actually created by Christopher
steel himself the author of the dossier
this is this is outrageous that this
happened will you vote to release the
Democrats memo yeah we will when does
that go into habit but it has to go
through the it has to go through the
same process when do you think it'll so
hard hard to say I don't I don't know
yet we haven't even I have I've only
read through it once we're gonna have to
go through and scrub it again
and let's not forget these are the same
Democrats who never wanted to start an
investigation
these are same Democrats who blocked our
subpoenas or tried to block our
subpoenas back in August they tried to
block our opera our ability to go and
get the records from fusion gps that led
to a lot of the discoveries in this
investigation so these are not honest
actors they know they're not being
honest actors and you know I get tired
of playing whack-a-mole every day with
the Democrats on this committee who
never wanted to start this investigation
in the first place Democrats are
criticizing a lot as you can imagine I'm
sure you've heard but they're jumping on
one particular part of the memo in
particular that the number for the memo
states that then Deputy Director of the
FBI Andrew McCabe quote testified before
the committee in December 2017 that no
surveillance warrant would have been
sought from the FISA Court without the
steal dossier information Democrats say
he never said that did he yeah yeah I
mean this is it's a summation of a long
interview and that is definitely what he
said not to mention we have other
witnesses who said very similar things
so that the fact of the matter is the
main the main things that were used to
go out and get this and get this warrant
was the dossier and the story that
cooperated the dossier when a minute has
quote in there or released the
transcript well that would be a whole
process that we'd have to go through
actually the quotes I think are pretty
damning themselves so it would I
wouldn't mind doing that but we would
have to go through a whole process to
release transcripts so you were getting
to the point about how much of the FISA
applications
relied on the steel dossier what was the
characteristic you said they were
integral or it was integral yeah they
would never received a warrant without
the dossier the dossier was was
presented to the court as it was as if
it was true the court was not told that
the Democrats actually paid for this and
just step back for a moment this is not
trying to go after some terrorists this
is about they opened the FBI opened a
counterintelligence investigation into
the Trump campaign in the summer of 2016
that's what happened
and then they got a warrant on someone
in the Trump campaign using opposition
research paid for by the Democratic
Party and the Hillary Clinton campaign
that's what this is about and it's wrong
and it should never be done is it true
that the FBI led the FISA application
with the dossier yeah most of the the
largest percentage of the the entire
application has to do with the dossier
and then using the news story to
co-operate the dossier there are
Democrats on your committee talking on
another Channel today who insisted that
the FISA Court was told of the political
nature of this information ticketless is
there anything inappropriate do you
think about a partisan political
document the steel dossier being used in
an application to surveil an associate
of a presidential candidate in this case
Carter page especially if that fact is
not disclosed in the application is that
inherently wrong do you think Jake that
fact was disclosed it was disclosed to
the FISA Court that part of the evidence
was from a politically motivated source
true I know I mean there's this as
things I said earlier I mean these guys
tell so many lies you can't keep track
of them that's not true
no court would the court was not made
aware and I would think that a judge if
the judge knew that hey we're opening
that we have an investigation of the
Trump campaign we're going after this
Trump campaign advisor and oh by the way
Hillary Clinton's campaign paid for all
this information if if that did happen
which it didn't but if that if that
Court did know that the judge would have
to be I think considered very suspect
but I don't believe that that that that
happened at all the former FBI director
James Comey I know you heard in John's
piece tweeted out that's it and went on
to criticize this entire operation your
thoughts on that tweet and commis
reaction well mr. Comey had a chance in
January February March April I believe
all the way till June to come clean on
who paid for the dossier he was asked
about it in January and he said very
clearly that he knew that Republicans
had
started the dossier which was a lie and
then when asked and probe further well
who finished the dossier he didn't know
now maybe he was lying maybe he didn't
know but both seemed to be a problem so
mr. Coombe he's welcome to come back
tell us when exactly he learned the
Democratic Party and the Hillary Clinton
campaign paid for the dossier he's
welcome to come back and share that
information but but I think the American
people understand that the FBI should
not go to secret courts using
information that was paid for by the
Democrats to open up investigations get
warrants on people of the other
political party now cook type of stuff
that happens in banana republics Comey
said in testimony that some of the
dossier is unverified and salacious are
there parts of the dossier that are true
what that Russia is a country and Carter
page as a person I mean other than that
I don't know anything so you don't know
anything that would corroborate 'add by
intel as a part of that dust yet know
very little and i think i think if you
actually look at that dossier from the
beginning i don't know what FBI agent
what they were smoking that they would
think that carter page who somebody who
doesn't who hasn't had a job for many
years who is obviously a russian
sympathizer but that somehow the
russians who actually said he was an
idiot in court testimony this was
presented before the court so russian
agent said that carter page was an idiot
and do you think that the russians were
gonna offer him like a 19% share of the
major oil company in russia i mean this
is crazy and so when somebody first
reads that dossier i would think you
would come away from that and think okay
this is really pretty what this is wild
stuff and that it was probably there's a
good chance let's not forget where the
dossier came from it came from russians
so so there's clear evidence of
collusion with the russians it just
happens to be with a Hillary Clinton
campaign in the Democratic National
Committee that the news media fails to
talk about or fails to even investigate
mr. chairman you know faces
controversial to begin with it was
challenged for reauthorization section
702 recently members often look for
reasons to vote against FISA some of
them civil liberties
turns wasn't the cart before the horse
here was the memo withheld until physis
section 702 was voted on by Congress no
so
so remember 702 is different it
understood it's different it still
affects it affects the overall
authorization but we found no abuses
within 702 I made that clear to my
colleagues don't forget the FBI and DOJ
stonewalled us we had to subpoena
documents in August we had several
meetings all through the fall trying to
get documents remember in at the
beginning of January people tend to
forget this when the FBI director and
mr. Rosenstein tried to do an end run
about around our committee and attempted
to go to the speaker so that we would
not hold them and contend that was not
until that was not until just a few
weeks ago so it 10th there were
supposedly a meeting where Rosen Stein
comes up to you about document
production and it got fairly heated is
that accurate
look I I mean I've had several meetings
with mr. Rosen Stein and I like him
personally and I think that he can fix
the problems over at DOJ and we're
willing to work with him so you don't
think he should be fired from his job
well look if that's not my decision
all I can say is that that mr.
Rosenstein has a long career but look
he's never really been in Washington DC
but you know there are some Mercer who
are using this to question the Muller
investigation are you separating the two
well I think what's happening is I think
the mainstream media and the Democrats
are tying this to the Moller
investigation because they're trying to
perpetuate this nonsense of obstruction
of justice because they've left the
Russia collusion issue they know there
was no collusion and and you know I've
been saying this for a year now that
there was no evidence of collusion
are there other so now you fast forward
are there other members and memos that
are going to come out
are there other memos you said this was
phase one yeah so this so this completes
just the FISA abuse portion of our
investigation we are we are in the
middle of what I call phase two of our
investigation which involves other
departments specifically the state
and some of the involvement that they
had in this that investigation is
ongoing and we continue to work towards
finding answers and asking the right
questions to try to get to the bottom of
what exactly the State Department was up
to in terms of this Russian
investigation quickly mr. chairman some
people have called you a Russian agent
others have said you should be fired the
barbs today on cable TV were pretty
amazing your thoughts in dealing with
all of this in the job that you have
yeah it's actually quite enjoyable
because I because we have the underlying
facts we've been investigating this for
a really long time so you know that
you're over the target when you're being
attacked from all sides mr. chairman we
said leave it there the computers going
to cut us off we appreciate the time sir
and we will follow it up Thank You Brett
thank you